After being on the air for nearly 30 years
and more than 600 episodes, there really aren't
many aspects of life that haven't been touched
upon by The Simpsons.
As surreal as their animated adventures may
be, from time to time, life imitates art.
We've lost count of the times that bizarre
storylines from Springfield actually came
true, but here are just a few occasions when
The Simpsons freakishly predicted the future.
President Trump
One of many episodes that showed an alternate-reality
future for Springfield's first family, "Bart
to the Future" aired in the year 2000, and
we learn Lisa has just been elected President
of the United States.
During her first cabinet meeting, President
Simpson mentions a familiar name.
"As you know, we've inherited quite a budget
crunch from President Trump."
We all know how the future turned out.
It's worth mentioning that this particular
episode was written during Donald Trump's
failed presidential run in the year 2000,
and the writers themselves saw the possibility
of a Trump presidency as the most ridiculous
thing they could imagine for the future…
which can only mean that Lisa Simpson is up
next.
And then?
President Kang.
"All hail President Kang!"
Could be worse.
We could be eating Soylent, which is literally
named after ground-up people from a sci-fi
movie starring Charlton Heston.
Wait…
"Soylent is food.
While not intended to replace every meal,
Soylent can replace any meal."
"Blech!
Oh, what a bleak, horrible future we live
in!"
All you can eat
In 1992's "New Kid on the Block," Homer sees
a TV commercial for an all-you-can-eat seafood
restaurant called the Frying Dutchman.
Homer proceeds to eat until closing time,
and gets kicked out…while still hungry.
He sues the restaurant for false advertising,
but Homer and the Sea Captain come to an agreement.
"Come see Bottomless Pete, nature's cruelest
mistake.
Come for the freak, stay for the food!"
In 2012, Bill Wisth went to a Wisconsin restaurant
called Chuck's Place for its weekly Friday
night fish fry buffet.
After a few trips to the restaurant — and
racking up a running tab — he wanted more,
but the restaurant claimed they'd run out.
That's when Wisth refused to pay.
"We asked for more fish and they refused to
give us any more fish."
The owner of Chuck's Place claimed Wisth had
eaten more than 20 pieces of fish…and was
violating the buffet's "no sharing" policy.
He came back, with a vengeance.
"And he wasn't done.
He came back two days later, with a picket
sign."
Wisth planned on picketing every day, but
by early 2013, he'd already moved on to other
protests.
But really…
"Did these sound like the actions of a man
who had ALL he could eat?"
"No!"
"That could have been me!"
People unknowingly ate gym mats
Over the course of the series, the secrets
of Springfield Elementary's lunchroom cost-cutting
have been explored again and again, but even
Lunchlady Doris has her limits.
"Where do you want these beef hearts?"
"On the floor."
In the 1995 episode "The PTA Disbands," even
Doris objects to using shredded newspaper
and old gym mats as ingredients.
"Posh!
Shredded newspapers add much needed roughage
and essential inks.
Besides, they didn't notice the old gym mats."
"There's very little meat in these gym mats."
In 2014, a minor but disgusting scandal developed
when the Environmental Working Group released
a report that found a compound called azodicarbonamide
in around 500 processed food products, primarily
breads, including Pillsbury Dinner Rolls,
your favorite five dollar footlongs, and Wonder
Bread.
So, if you've ever wondered what put the "wonder"
in Wonder Bread… it's yoga mats, and yoga
is totally healthy.
The baby translator
By Season Two, Homer had met his long-lost
brother Herb, but he leaves Herb in financial
ruin after he bets his whole car manufacturing
business on a ridiculous car Homer designs.
Which was called "The Homer," obviously.
"Any questions?"
Left destitute, he moves in with the Simpsons,
where he creates a baby translator that turns
an infant's noises into English.
"Maggie.
Maggie!"
"Where did you go?"
"Peekaboo!"
"Oh, there you are.
Very amusing."
The episode originally aired in 1992, and
by the year 2004, Japanese tech and toy company
Takara developed a real-life prototype of
something very similar, after previously selling
a device that analyzed the sounds of dogs
barking.
The prototype analyzed a baby's sounds, facial
expressions, and body temperature to alert
parents if the baby was hungry, tired, or
needed to be changed.
While the final product never emerged, other
companies took the reins and produced other
devices to analyze the fleshy, wet, loud riddles
that are infants, ensuring that you'll always
be able to completely emotionally detach from
your helpless offspring.
A donut-shaped universe
At the end of "They Saved Lisa's Brain," a
1999 episode in which Lisa and her local MENSA
chapter attempt to rule Springfield with their
superior intellect, the smartest guy in the
world makes a cameo: physicist and cosmologist
Stephen Hawking.
And he has some interesting ideas.
"Your theory of a donut-shaped universe is
intriguing, Homer.
I may have to steal it."
"Wow."
Technically, the shape of a donut is a torus.
And yes, as it turns out, the universe may
actually be shaped like the delicious confection.
Four years after Homer Simpson "proposed"
the theory, cosmologists noticed radiation
patterns in space suggesting that the universe
was round and tube-like, but "empty" in the
middle.
And that's not the only time Homer's been
the smartest man in Springfield.
"I am so smart!
I am so smart!
S-M-R-T!
I mean, S-M-A-R-T!"
The Higgs boson
While first proposed in 1964, it wasn't until
2013 that physicists discovered the Higgs
boson, the field that basically holds atoms
together.
In other words, the discovery helps to define
the very fabric of existence, and helps to
explain how the universe and matter work.
And once again, Homer was on the cutting edge
of science.
In the 1998 episode "The Wizard of Evergreen
Terrace," Homer attempts to become a scientist
and inventor, and is seen messing around with
some formulas on a chalkboard.
His meaningless math actually gets pretty
close to the the actual molecular weight of
the Higgs particle, which, out of an infinite
possible equations, is pretty impressive.
But more importantly, when is reality going
to finally catch up with the toilet chair?
"Believe me, every man in America will want
to have one."
"Gang way, gotta poop!"
Lady Gaga
The halftime show of the 2017 Super Bowl made
headlines, with Lady Gaga delivering a performance
that was absolutely surreal, featuring high-wire
stunts, pyrotechnics, and theatrical costumes.
Having provided her own voice for her 2012
appearance on The Simpsons, Gaga was definitely
familiar with her earlier animated performance,
which bore some striking similarities to her
Super Bowl show.
Granted, Gaga's Springfield self was only
a slight exaggeration on her normally outlandish
persona…
"It's me, Gaga!
Why is everyone looking at my purple hair
full of bluebirds?"
...but this one is pretty spot-on.
The Albuquerque Isotopes
The 2001 episode "Hungry, Hungry Homer" is
all about Homer going on a hunger strike to
prevent the local minor league baseball team,
the Springfield Isotopes, from secretly moving
to Albuquerque.
"Dancing away my hunger pangs.
Moving my feet so my stomach won't hurt."
In 2002, the minor league Calgary Cannons
announced a move to Albuquerque, and the local
paper published a poll asking readers to come
up with a new name for the team.
No strangers to pop culture, the name "Isotopes"
won with 67 percent of the vote.
While the idea very clearly came from The
Simpsons, "Isotopes" is appropriate for a
team moving so close to the Los Alamos National
Laboratory.
At least the power plants in New Mexico can't
possibly be as bad as in Springfield, right?
"Well, in Southern New Mexico, federal officials
have confirmed that a local nuclear power
plant is leaking waste and releasing radiation
into the surrounding area."
Nope.
Those suck too.
Stay safe, Isotopes.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!